iPod is an MP3 music player, has CD quality music,...
…and it plays all of the popular open formats of digital music.
Sure, you recognize that man.
That's the late Apple CEO and co-founder, Steve Jobs,...
...introducing the iPod back in 2001.
That is some vintage video there.
Alright, more than twenty years later,...
...the company has announced it is discontinuing the once revolutionary MP3 players.
Apple said Tuesday, the iPod Touch will only be available while remaining stocks last,...
...so act fast if you want to get your hands on one.
This marks the end of an iconic product...
...that ushered in a new era for the music industry and for technology.
Apple consumers will still be able to listen to songs through other devices,...
...including the iPhone, iPad, and the Apple Watch.
CBS News tech reporter Dan Patterson joins us now for more on this.
Dan, frankly, I didn't know they were still making and manufacturing iPods.
But, I guess, you know, first of all, what happened to the iPod?
Well, look, it had a long and storied career,...
…but eventually, those features that were so iconic twenty years ago...
...were just absorbed into other products.
Let's start at the top, the most important feature that it was marketed as: music.
Well, instead of downloading or buying songs for 99 cents a piece,...
...we just stream Apple Music or Spotify.
But the other features, look, I mean, the iPod Touch is really just an iPhone...
...without the SIM card, without the calling ability.
So, Apple could have, in theory, kept it in parity, feature to feature.
But, it really just lost out in terms of popularity to that communication device...
…that we all have in our pocket that Steve Jobs built as three products in one.
That's the iPhone.